last year's winner was Alexandra emini
from Dublin he was 15 when he won the
competition with his work on tennis
sensor data analysis but it didn't stop
there as Donna Sullivan has been finding
out
succeeding at the BT young scientist
competition is all about hard work and
no one exemplifies this more than last
year's winner Alexander and meaning he
arrived in Ireland from New York with
his family just two years ago quickly
set his sights on the competition it was
really something that came to me like
overnight because I play a lot of tennis
and it was just the idea of trying to
create a system to help tennis players
because coaching can be so expensive
it's something that is such a luxury for
tennis athletes to have something like a
program that can provide real-time
feedback unbiased feedback to an athlete
in real time is just a necessity for
every times athlete that Alexander has
been playing from a very early age so it
probably wasn't surprising he chose to
incorporate it in his project my whole
family faced Imus actually so I have two
sisters and one brother we all play
tennis my dad started us to play tennis
and he's been all of our coach so my
project is just a motion refinement and
recognition system so I told my project
for tennis in specific but what it does
is just recognizes the type of motions
that the athlete or person is performing
and then tries to provide feedback on
how to improve these motions Alexander
used the facilities here at tennis
Ireland in DCU for his project as their
courts can be found from several
different angles from cameras located
high on the walls Alexandre used the raw
data from tennis sessions played here to
write his own computer program which can
interpret how good your tennis swing is
from the signal sent from a motion
sensor worn on the wrist
he used 13 different computer languages
to write the software and unsurprisingly
wowed the judges
young scientists and technologists of
the year 2011 Alexander this I have to
say is well the best ones we've ever
seen and we're level in terms of
research this is an excellent project it
would compare to an honours
undergraduate degree level or even
postgraduate degree level research
project
he has taken a very complex problem he's
applied very complicated techniques to
try and solve the problem and he's
brought up to completion it's a really
good piece of work and it has an
immediate practical application as a
tennis coach myself it's fantastic to
have the tool to empty use with tennis
players to help them develop their
strokes and to to analyze his stroke so
it's an incredible and sovereign has
done very well with a chair of course it
didn't end there Alexander's project was
automatically entered into the European
Union contest for young scientists and
again won first prize was four or five
days and the atmosphere in the
exhibition was also incredible because
you have top competitors they're winners
of their national competition all coming
together to compete again that is just
being recognized or something like that
you pour your heart and soul into
working on it so constantly to be
recognized for something like that is
just a huge honor of course everyone at
his school in Castle Rock college
couldn't be brighter and the first day
he arrived until this very moment he's
been just tough class an absolutely
excellent student very dedicated he said
to me on the first day when he wanted to
do the young scientist project sir I'm
going to win it and he wanted I started
to laugh but I shouldn't have but he
very dedicated he doesn't sleep he works
and works and works nobody actually
realizes how hard he works rising tide
lifts all boats and the entry this year
have never had more entries into the old
scientists
it also has increased the uptake of
science subjects by our
with three classes to leave us our
biology the hard work hasn't ended for
Alexandra though he skipped a school
year in order to do the Leaving Cert
early this July and he's continuing to
develop his project I've had two patents
on my project and I hope to develop it
further in the coming months and years
it's applicable to tennis but also a
wide range of other field so I'd love to
start testing on things like medical
applications and sports rehabilitation
medical rehabilitation
things like this I think it has much
more application than something like
tennis
congratulations once again to Alexander
and we wish him the very best for the
future